welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast in today's episode Greg and I
answer listener questions about the
optimal rate of weight gain while
bulking rep ranges for hypertrophy
soreness concurrent training a variety
of recovery modalities and more to
finish off the episode Greg and I talked
about why research should still be
valued and applied despite the
likelihood that there's probably some
low quality research hiding within the
literature out there if you want your
questions answered on a future episode
we now have a new process for submitting
questions questions can be submitted by
typing in the URL tiny dot CC / SBS QA
or you can just click on the link in the
episode description as always thank you
for listening and we hope you enjoy
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast we're here with another Q&A
episode before we get into business we
do want to address something because
there's a lot of rumors flying around a
lot of misinformation on the Internet
so Greg and I did a lasagna cook-off not
too long ago and the results were in
there were some initial results coming
out that weren't quite legitimate hadn't
been really verified yet basically what
went down is people ate my lasagna and
literally people said things such as
quote I could eat this where's the
cottage cheese which came up that was a
big point of contention a lot of people
were worried can Eric masterfully kind
of put that into the lasagna food matrix
yes people could not find it they had no
idea so all in all flavor-wise
texture-wise presentation-wise it I
would say it was probably about a draw
but tie goes to the lowest macros so I
think I came out on top
yeah so that's actually not at all what
happened so it was so painfully obvious
on the front end that it was going to be
an absolute bloodbath that Eric's
girlfriend actually defected to team
Greg about 48 hours beforehand was my
ex-girlfriend
[Laughter]
so Eric's current girlfriend and we made
beautiful homemade noodles homemade meat
sauce homemade cheesy bechamel it was
absolutely incredible of the six people
there five of them said that it was the
best homemade lasagna they'd ever had
the only one that didn't was Eric for
obvious reasons it was just it was
possibly the biggest runaway victory in
any cook-off that has ever occurred if
if you were paying attention to my
Instagram story that night you saw the
cross-sections of Eric's it was one just
an objectively sad cross-section and two
not the cross-section of the lasagna I
think if anything I won by default
because I was the only one that made a
lasagna that was entered into the
competition creativity counts yours was
a joke there was no it wasn't inspired
there was no unique spin on it I pushed
the boundaries of lasagna if you wanted
this qualify it for being creative
that's on you it was arguably a chicken
dip what was a good chicken dip if
that's what you're calling it one could
construe it as a passable chicken dip
but not a lasagna okay so I thought we'd
reached a conclusion here clearly
there's still a lot of misinformation so
we're just gonna leave it in the past I
never talked about it again
completely unrelated note please keep
applying for the co-host position for
this podcast I get a lot of good
applications and as things get more and
more tense between Greg and I believe me
I'm looking through them all hours of
the day trying to find the right fit and
also on that same topic keep blowing up
Erickson box lobbying to have me stay on
as the co-host several hundred of you so
far have messaged him to voice support
for me staying on I don't think we'll be
able to to crack through his rough outer
shell until at least probably three to
four thousand people message him so if
you're listening to this shoot Eric
message say you got a good thing going
with the podcast now don't ruin it
keep Greg on every single one of you
needs to message his personal inbox on
Facebook or Instagram let him know
honestly so some people have done that
and every message I get gets me closer
to firing his ass so if you think you're
helping you're just making me extremely
angry and you're putting Greg's
livelihood in jeopardy as it pertains to
this show all right you want to get into
some questions let's do it all right so
question we have leading off is for Eric
very straightforward question so Eric
slow gain versus bulking which I assume
implies a faster rate of weight gain
what are the pros and cons so this one
is it's pretty intuitive a lot of people
well whenever somebody kind of lands on
the goal that they want to put on some
some mass now the question is how much
and how quickly and I mean the pros and
cons are pretty obvious when you go with
a slow rate of weight gain you're
probably going to increase the
proportion of lean mass that's gained
relative to fat mass most likely you're
probably gonna minimize falling into
that trap where yeah you gain some lean
mass but you added a ton of fat in the
process because you were just in a huge
caloric surplus now the downside of that
is theoretically you could be leaving
some gains on a table so it is possible
that you are gaining lean mass at a
slower rate than you otherwise could
have if your caloric intake was a little
higher so you know it's obviously very
tricky to strike that balance and
there's pros pros and cons of going slow
and there's pros and cons of going more
rapidly with it unequivocally going slow
with your weight gain is far less fun so
dreamer bulks are awesome and a dreamer
bulk if you're not familiar with the
terminology but they call it a dreamer
bulk because you just delude yourself
into thinking like oh I'm clearly just
getting huge when in reality you're
putting on like a ton of fat but I think
everyone that's kind of big data at
least one dreamer bulk in their career
what do you say yeah probably so I think
everybody has and the food choices when
you're doing a dreamer bulk are just off
the charts awesome so like there was a
time where I was eating a pizza every
day couple pounds of chicken a few
grilled cheese sandwiches like eight
eggs and this was all in the same day it
was just calories on top of calories and
it was awesome the problem was I think
I've told this story on the podcast
before at a certain point I was getting
a lot stronger putting on size but my
very trusted roommate a great friend of
mine named Nick pulled me aside and said
hey Eric no one likes you enough to tell
you this but you're getting really fat
and and at the time I was dumbfounded
because I had bought into the dreamer
bulk I was like no I'm just getting huge
and he's like nope no you're pretty fat
and then I looked in the mirror I was
like oh no you're correct so there's a
balance to be struck their funny story
is when I was fully bulked up in my
dreamer bulk I did get struck by an
automobile when I was crossing the
street and and I really believe that if
I wasn't just completely bloated and
bulked up and just full of padding I
really think that would have gone worse
if I took the lean gain kind of approach
so I not lean gains like intermittent
famine but if I took the slower rate of
weight gain and stayed lean I'm not sure
how well I would have absorbed that car
so sometimes dreamer bulk save lives I
would say so it was pretty wild like I
got nailed by the car it was completely
fine so so Eric have you heard the the
classic West Side Story of JM Blakely's
diet I believe I believe you've told me
but ok so so for the listeners who have
never heard of this it's it's a
legendary story I don't know who shared
it with the masses first but JM Blakeley
was a bench specialist who trained at
Westside barbell and I want to say at
one point he had all of the multi ply
bench records from like 181 all the way
up to 275 it may have been 198 up to 275
but
very wide range of weight classes and he
took those records in pretty quick
succession starting with the lighter
weight classes and just working up from
there and so I forget who it was it may
have been Dave Tate but don't quote me
on that but someone new came to Westside
they were having trouble putting on
weight filling out their weight class
and so either JM pulled pulled this
individual aside or someone who JM had
told his secrets to pull this individual
aside they're like you're having trouble
gaining weight here's what you got to do
if you want to get big and jacked so
every day for breakfast you need to go
to McDonald's get like for breakfast
sandwiches get for hashbrowns put the
hash browns on the breakfast sandwich
get four things of mayonnaise put like a
whole package of mayonnaise on each one
of these hash brown breakfast sandwich
combos eat that that's your breakfast
for lunch you're gonna go to a Chinese
buffet make sure it is not a no MSG
Chinese buffet so you'll be able to keep
eating longer sit down
don't get up except to get more food for
like an hour and a half just eat
everything you possibly can at least
four or five solid plates of food and
then for dinner you're gonna get an
extra large pizza you're gonna drizzle
an extra like cup of olive oil over top
of it you're gonna eat that whole pizza
that's your dinner and then you also
need to get like eight king size
Snickers bars and eat those throughout
the day as well as snacks between meals
and so yeah all of that up it's like
12,000 calories or something and
apparently that's how JM Blakeley you
know went from 181 to 275 or whatever it
was and so that became kind of like lore
within that subculture but the part of
that story that people don't tell is to
the best of my knowledge
JM never cut back down to 180 one to
defend that record that was a one-way
street fellas that was dietary advice
going purely in one direction
so that is a thing to keep in mind like
if I could go back with my dreamer bulk
scenario I I do kind of regret letting
my body fat get as high as it did
because it just made the subsequent cut
that much harder I mean you can lose it
but I are to some extent kind of digging
a hole to get out of now getting to
actual like useful numbers here there's
a couple really good review papers
recently that I believe they're both
open access which means you don't need
some kind of license to read them or
anything
one is by slater at all the other by
iraqi at all both in 2019 so very recent
and they're talking about basically how
important is it to be in a caloric
surplus when you're trying to gain
muscle and also what are some offseason
guidelines for people that are
interested in physique competition so
basically bodybuilding now generally
speaking what you what you take away
from these two papers is the probably
the ideal approach for most folks is
aiming to gain about 0.25 to 0.5% of
body weight per week and to put you in
the ballpark of achieving that you're
probably getting your calories about 10
to 20 percent above the maintenance
level that you would need purely to
maintain body weight now if you're super
experienced you might want to go slower
if you believe that you've gained a lot
of the muscle that you stand to gain in
your career and you don't have that much
left to add before you're kind of at
your limit
genetically then you'd probably want to
go slower because at that point you
don't need to be over feeding to
capitalize on these rapid huge muscle
gains because they're probably not
coming whereas if you're completely new
to this stuff you can absolutely gain
gain at a faster rate than that or at
least toward the higher end of that
range so you have to kind of be honest
with yourself about you know how much
weight do do I really think I can pack
on from where I'm at now and if you've
got a lot of room to go you can go a
little bit faster with it but if you're
kind of near what you perceive is you're
kind of as good as you're gonna get in
terms of
and be honest with yourself because I
think a lot of people underestimate a
lot of people live for like six months
and they're like well I guess this is it
and they actually could could go quite a
lot further with it
but one other caveat to keep in mind you
have to think of you know what's your
end goal you know you don't want to put
on a ton of body fat if your end goal is
to get shredded so think of that think
of where you are in your lifting career
beginner intermediate advanced and then
also you're going to want to account for
the fact that some people have a pretty
large and robust adaptive increase in
energy expenditure when they start
overeating so some people and it's been
well documented in the research
literature if you start over feeding
them their their energy expenditure
ramps up like crazy and they're actually
quite resistant to weight gain despite
the fact that you're trying to overfeed
them so you never really know where
you're gonna fall on that spectrum till
you try but so so one one thing just to
restate what Eric just said that that I
do think people get confused about is if
you're currently at maintenance and
let's say at maintenance you're eating
2,500 calories a day for example and
then you increase calorie intake by 300
calories a day and so now you're eating
2800 calories a day and like you don't
gain any weight or don't gain hardly any
weight I see a lot of people looking to
that and saying like dude I'm in a 300
calorie surplus and nothing is happening
by definition you're not in a 300
calorie surplus you are still at
maintenance and adaptations have taken
place either metabolically or via NEET
to keep you still at maintenance but
just at a higher maintenance level yeah
maintenance is arranged not a number yes
and so if you acutely over feet or under
feet you're going to see that
maintenance number shift around a little
bit so that that's exactly what I'm
getting at is the fact that you know in
the I think it was the Iraqi paper where
they gave that 0.25 to 0.5% body weight
per week I think that's the one of those
two papers that it came from but that is
a you know they say
about a 10 or 20% increase in calories
above maintenance but it's so hard to
tell how much your energy expenditure is
gonna ramp up when you start over
feeding so you really have to play it by
ear you have to watch the scale closely
and that's the biggest mistake people
make when they're trying to gain muscle
and are really concerned about gaining
fat is they try to put their bulk at a
rate of weight gain that is
exceptionally slow and it's it's almost
so slow that the human eye can't see it
on a scale you know what I mean it your
day to day weight is gonna fluctuate by
I don't know a couple pounds give or
take you know depending on how large you
are and so we're talking about gaining
you know decimals you know tenths of
pounds over a couple weeks when people
try to take this really slow approach
and they're like well not working and so
the really tricky thing is finding that
balance where you can actually keep an
eye on your you know you're making
enough progress to track it and you're
not just scrapping the whole plan and
saying screw it tried it didn't work so
I think the the out the recommend -
recommendations that they outline in
slater at all and iraq yet all are a
really good starting point and then from
there you got to play it by ear and
watch a scale so can i just tell us
another question in here yes so this
comes from our list of Q&A questions
people have submitted I forget who asked
it but I thought it was a pretty good
question and I think it it dovetails
pretty well off of your answer to the
previous question so what this person
asked was basically one of the things
you said leading off your answer to that
question is you know most people who are
in fitness either string sports or
physique sports have done a dreamer bulk
at some point like you have I have
virtually everyone I know who's been
lifting for at least 10 years has at
some point or another done a dream or
bulk and generally fairly early in their
training process and so I mean you
recommend a pretty conservative surplus
generally I do to pretty much everyone I
know does yet we all went through that
dreamer bulk so do you think that
there's some sort
of conflict they're like you know we've
clearly got maybe not to the place we
want to be but we've made some good
gains one of the things we did along the
way was a dreamer bulk and we're telling
people not to do what we did so is there
some hypocrisy there or do you think
it's more like we learned our lesson
from our dreamer bulks I would say it's
more the the the latter I feel like I
learned my lesson from the dreamer bulk
you know what I mean um I could be wrong
maybe it's the one thing that we all
think we did wrong and actually is the
secret to get getting decently big and
strong but I lean toward the other
scenario that is I feel like in the time
that I gained all that mass I feel like
I could have taken it a little bit not
even slower but I just could not over
eaten by so much and taking a slightly
more calculated and thoughtful approach
because literally it was just like I'm
gonna eat until I feel sick mm-hmm every
meal and just try it's like like you
were saying with with the diet you laid
out I think the quote from if you're
talking about the same article I'm
thinking of it was like screw it
olive oil canola oil anything but motor
oil right yeah yeah yeah that was the
exact article yeah so it's like that
it's the beauty of that approach is its
simplicity mm-hmm I'm going to lift like
I'm trying to kill myself with the
weights and I'm going to eat everything
I could possibly eat if you do that
you're probably you're probably gonna
grow mm-hmm but the question is like did
you then add on a bunch of fat that you
didn't want to add on and then required
you to do more cutting than you would
have wanted to and for me that's the
spot I got to because I transitioned
right from that dreamer bulk into a
contest prep like it because I literally
this is a true story I got hit by the
damn car and then I realized like oh I'm
healthy and I'm not injured and I
probably should be injured but like I
had never done bodybuilding and I was
like I better give this a shot before I
get myself hurt in the gym or walk in
front of another car yeah and and so
yeah I went straight from a dreamer bulk
into a contest prep and
you know I had to cut a good 40 pounds
to not even get that lean because like I
wasn't only I like won the novice
category but would not have done damage
in the open yeah like way too fat so so
yeah I mean I think I learned my lesson
where I was like oh this could have been
a lot easier if I didn't if instead of
eating four grilled cheeses after the
pizza if I had two mm-hmm I still would
have made the gains you know so that I
don't know do you feel differently I do
kind of wonder if it's different for
strength athletes and physique athletes
and especially I would say probably for
for drug-free strength athletes who
maybe just naturally have a somewhat
higher body fat setpoint so one of the
things that I've seen with like not a
tremendously large number of lifters but
a decent amount is people who like you
know I've gotten to know them well
enough that I know that they were fat
kids you know like before they got into
sports before they got into string
sports like they were chubby little kids
and then they get into lifting they get
pretty lean they wind up in a weight
class that looks like on paper it should
be pretty good for them and then they
stall out hard there and just say you
know [ __ ] it gonna get big put on a fair
amount of weight not always super high
quality weight like they probably did
put on proportionally quite a bit more
fat than muscle but then when they move
up to the next weight class even though
their body comp is worse not only are
they way stronger but they're wilkes
core is also better and so I wonder if
like I wonder like if in a general sense
getting leaner probably shouldn't on
average hurt people's strength all that
much but for people who were like chubby
or growing up if for whatever reason I
don't know what the mechanism would be
you're just for whatever reason stronger
at a slightly higher body fat level so I
mean I don't think that that would be an
argument for dreamer bulking from
already being at a higher body fat level
but maybe if
you did get lien at some point doing a
bit of a dreamer bulk you know not like
putting on fifty pounds but putting on
like 20 may do something for you
yeah that's one of the things that's
always perplexed me and I don't think I
have a good answer for it but when I was
like really bulked up and like pretty I
had a lot of padding on me mm-hmm
I was strong yeah I mean I dude it
wasn't muscle but God I was strong like
adipose tissue does not have contractile
function but there there are times that
I question that like like I know it
doesn't but sometimes I wonder dude I
mean you've seen me bench a million
times when I was all balked up and fat
and stuff it's 350 was not a problem
mm-hmm and I'm not touching that right
now yeah I'm not even close but yeah
I've seen the same thing I it's it's one
of those questions that has bothered me
probably since I was 20 years old why
was I so strong when I was fat because
it wasn't powerful yeah you probably
have more muscle now than you did then
probably yeah yeah I don't get it man
yeah I don't know I think that's one of
those things where several folks when
I've just like gotten them alone and had
a conversation with them about this we
all kind of acknowledge like yeah there
seemed to be a fair amount of people
that you know get them up to about 20%
body fat they're just way [ __ ]
stronger than they are at 15%
but but that's not something that people
talk about publicly because there
there's no known mechanism that would
explain why that would be the case and
so I think people don't want to put that
take out there because they know they
don't have an explanation for it but I I
mean I think it's a legitimate
occurrence but I don't feel comfortable
even attempting to to speculate about
why it would be no and the funny thing
is if you're like if you're in the
powerlifting bodybuilding like hybrid
world not which is where I occupied for
a while
so everyone convinces themselves they're
like oh my numbers are nice I'm used to
cutting
25 pounds whenever I feel like it if I
just keep all my strength and cut 25
pounds I swear I've tricked myself into
that probably three different probably
three different times since I was like
at that I think that's because I grew up
in wrestling mm-hmm and so it's you're
like well if I'm this strong at 160 what
if I wrestled 119 mm-hmm it's like well
then you're not gonna be strong anymore
I think yeah but I convinced myself I
was gonna be like the greatest 1:48
lifter on the planet based on my like
185 lifts and then the second I lost
like five pounds I was like oh I'm weak
again yeah yeah that's that's how it
goes man yeah all right Greg let's let's
switch gears here and we've got a
question for you from anyone NC 19 the
question is Greg how do routines with
sets of 20 to 30 reps differ for
hypertrophy when compared to similar
volume sets of eight to twelve
repetitions is the response similar so
if if by similar volume you mean same
number of sets performed to failure or
close to failure then yeah hypertrophy
is gonna be pretty similar if you mean
hypertrophy in terms of like volume load
then I would assume you'd get more
hypertrophy doing the sets of eight to
twelve but also we've talked about this
on the podcast before I've talked about
this on stronger by science volume load
isn't a great metric for most
applications so if you're talking about
set volume then on a per set basis
assuming sets are taken pretty close to
failure hypertrophy should be similar
however one thing that I think is
important to note here is you have to
consider the question of practicality so
you know like let's say doing 3 sets of
20 RM squats and doing 3 sets of 8 RM
squats are going to get you pretty
similar hypertrophy that's a cool little
tidbit to know but if you were setting
up a training program and you're gonna
do you know three hard sets of eight or
three hard sets of 20
twice a week for the next 16 weeks and
you can get the same gains from either
one of those setups virtually everyone's
gonna go with the sets of eight because
the sets of 20 [ __ ] suck so if you
can get the same progress with less
general suckage you probably want to go
for the sets of eight to twelve and then
also like research isn't set up to
figure out what the maximal amount
someone could grow with like a perfectly
optimized program is like most most
studies use fairly conservative training
volumes just to make sure that you know
you don't wind up with a bunch of people
injured and your IRB mad at you so one
thing we also know is that higher weekly
set volumes tend to cause more muscle
growth and so you know let's say you're
trying to do 15 hard sets of quad work
per week that's probably going to be
very doable with sets of eight to twelve
it may be theoretically possible but
just just crush you if you're doing sets
of twenty to thirty for all fifteen of
those sets so like yeah the the answer
to that question is if you do equate the
number of sets doesn't really seem to
matter all that much what rep range you
train and within reason but practically
I think sets of maybe five to twelve
reps are what you see most people doing
in the gym for a reason that's a that's
a pretty wide rep range so you know if
you don't want to Train super heavy
maybe for joint issues or something kind
of go with the lighter higher rep end of
that range maybe if you're doing
something that is very metabolically
taxing like squats or deadlifts you
don't really want to do the sets of ten
to twelve maybe now you're doing sets of
five to eight like whatever but that's a
pretty big range it's where you see most
generally successful programs
gravitating towards I think there's a
reason for that like it gets you good
growth per set it generally sucks less
than the super high rep stuff and it's a
generally good practical range of reps
per set to train in the other thing I'll
say though is like the exercise you're
doing matters a lot so you know if sets
220 or sets of 20 are just as good as
sets of 8 to 12 for growth and you
really really like to get a huge pump
and a super intense burn when you're
doing arm work like sure do sets of 24
curls and tricep extensions like that's
perfectly fine and that's probably going
to be you know generally more enjoyable
and feasible than doing sets of 24
squats and deadlifts so yeah in theory
equate four sets similar hypertrophy
regardless of rep range practically kind
of maybe 5 to 12 ish reps per set is
generally what works best for most
people most of the time do you ever I
don't know if this is just me but there
are certain lifts that I don't let
myself do high rep ranges with so that
the two that come to mind for me
whenever I start letting my benchpress
repetitions get high
I really feel the wear and tear on my
shoulder a pre-existing injury same
thing with deadlifts and my old sacrum
issues part of me wonders if just you
know if I'm like okay I'm gonna bench a
set of 12 if because the load is so
light that on the first four I can have
bad enough technique to make my tissues
angry without like getting pinned under
the weight does that make any sense like
that I would make myself use heavier
loads where if I like miss groove it or
get lazy with technique like I will
acutely be completely screwed I guess I
could see that being because I won't
reticle II possible I won't touch a
bench press set over five reps not
interested so again I have no research
to back this up
but my my personal experience I think is
similar but different in that I don't
think it's so much form going
the first few reps when I'm not taking
it seriously I think it's more like so
one of the things one of the things that
you you often see for multi-joint
exercises is that whatever the like main
the main muscle contributing to it is
you see like pretty high muscle
activation for that muscle with pretty
like reasonably low loads and then the
other muscles that contribute to the
lift ramp up in activation either as
sets drag on or as you get to heavier
and heavier loads so basically so for
example there was a paper by Crowell and
golus from I think 2017 where they
looked at EMG of the pecs triceps front
delts and maybe Blatz
with loads ranging from 70% of one rep
max to 100% of one rep max and what they
saw with the pecs is that PEC EMG didn't
actually seem to change like virtually
any at all
between 70% loads and one rep max loads
but front delt EMG and especially tricep
EMG ramped up dramatically as loads
increased there's there's a paper I
believe by Robbins looking at multiple
reps on the squat finding something
similar so like from rep one quad EMG
was pretty high but EMG of the
hamstrings and hip extensors started
ramping up as people got closer to
failure and so a part of me wonders if
like when you're doing the really high
rep stuff since like the total amount of
fatigue you generate is greater which I
feel like is self-evidently true you
know if you put 90 percent on the bar
you know rep one you are 100 percent
strong
if you fail rep 4 that means your 10%
weaker than you were at the start of a
set if you put fifty percent on the bar
you know rep 1 you're 100 percent strong
when you eventually fail by rep 25 or
whatever you're 50% weaker than you were
at the start of a set so maybe just
because you can generate more fatigue
during the set you're getting more and
more of the muscles involved in the
movement that generally wouldn't be
quite as involved and that just fatigue
stuff that's not used to being fatigued
kind of like pull stuff in ways it's not
used to being pulled that's that's kind
of like my subjective experience with
higher up stuff because I do
occasionally throw in high rep squats
and deadlifts and like I'll get sore
from you know sets of five sets of eight
but I get a different kind of sore in
different places from the high rep stuff
so that's my that's my semi informed
take yeah I remember I did see a talk at
a conference several several years back
where somebody was looking at I forget
the the particulars of the study but it
was a really cool study where they a
fatigued the deltoids and watched the
mechanics of a particular shoulder
exercise throughout the course of the
workout mm-hmm and the joint geometry
really started to change like not the
actual structural geometry but the
articulation of the glenohumeral joint
as the surrounding musculature fatigued
it was changing the way they were moving
in a very meaningful way yeah such that
you could imagine like oh this is
probably shifting some of the strain to
structures that maybe don't want to be
shouldering much of that stress or I
wouldn't necessarily say wouldn't want
to be but just aren't as used to it
correct yeah yeah yeah so so yeah I
still wrestle with why that's the case
but it's like one of those things where
if you touch your stove enough times
eventually you stop touching it yeah and
like for me it's like I see like Oh
benches set at 12 I'm like I mean I'll
give you six doubles but I'm not doing
12 no yeah yeah I think it's um so the
the explanation I gave I already said
this but just to make super clear for
the listeners
I'm not saying a hundred percent for
sure that's what happens but based on my
experience and some of the research I've
seen that's again a semi informed take
on the
it makes sense to me all right next
question for you Eric how can we improve
sleep to help training sleeps getting
big I feel like more than ever you the
last couple of years you hear a lot more
people talking about sleep as it
pertains to athletes and training and
stuff like that which is a good thing
because I think I think we ignored it
for a long time like we used to always
say it was always like a thing of pride
like we got our guys in the gym at 4:00
in the morning it's like yeah but they
all went to bed at 11 yeah you know it's
like that's that's not a great burger
the whole like I'll sleep when I'm dead
well congrats bro like you're gonna die
20 years earlier now yeah yeah they have
a great opportunity for that so there
was a recent review paper by vitaliy at
all in 2019 open access so anybody can
read it what they did was within the
paper they gave a couple lists of
recommendations and instead of you know
running my mouth for 30 minutes and
trailing off I'm just gonna give you the
good stuff get right to the lists with
the highlights here so one was called
the healthy sleep hygiene top ten
recommendations and their source what
was the UCSD Center for pulmonary and
sleep medicine patient information
handout so they went ahead and re
published it right there in the paper
number one don't get it don't go to bed
until you're tired if you're in bed and
you're not tired get out of bed
go do something I think that's one that
I rarely hear but that's a really good
piece of advice like there's nothing
worse than just laying there and staring
at the ceiling not at all helpful for
your sleep habits number two get a
regular bedtime routine what's this face
you're making
that that first piece of advice actually
just like ruined my sleep for about five
years
why because you would just bail on the
concept of sleeping and go work I mean
dude so so people say you know humans
are supposed to you know have a natural
24-hour sleep-wake cycle I'm about to
tell like hey Greg as a special
snowflake story don't don't hear this
think that it's going to apply to you so
you know if I don't go to bed until I'm
sleepy I will generally just like pull
an all-nighter maybe like once out of
every three nights and it's not just you
know like when I don't have stimulants
in my system when I'm not on screens I
still just don't get tired until I don't
know maybe like 6 or 7 in the morning
and then at that point it's there's no
point in going to sleep because I'm
either gonna get like two hours or sleep
through the entire next day but this is
one of the reasons why like one of the
pieces of advice I was given when I
started having sleep issues is Oh read a
book to wind down that doesn't [ __ ]
work for me because I get engrossed in
what I'm reading and then next thing I
know it's 9 a.m.
my wife's waking up for the day and I'm
like 80% of the way done with the book
and I'm still not tired yet so like in
general that's probably good advice I
previously took that advice it didn't
work well for me now I just like force
myself to get my ass in bed sometimes I
stare at the ceiling for four hours but
I do on average sleep much more than I
used to yeah I mean no one should be
taking their sleep use for me your
situation is different like you're
you're the person in the sleep study
that has to have their data discarded no
yeah for sure yes what you've got going
on is strange but number one don't go to
bed till you're tired if you're not
tired get out of bed til you get tired
number two have a regular bedtime
routine you know reading a warm bath
don't unless you're Greg you know cuz
you start reading and all of a sudden
you're done with the book number three
try to get up the same time every
morning so routine is big for a lot of
people your bedtime routine what you do
before bed the time you go to bed the
time you wake up try to get a full
night's sleep this list says to avoid
naps I think people are moving away from
that in the sleep research I think naps
are getting a lot better press than they
used to but ideally I think this
scenario would be that you sleep so well
at night that you don't feel inclined to
take a nap later in the day
use your bed for sleep and intimacy only
don't do a bunch of other random stuff
in your bed don't be sitting in your bed
doing homework and stuff like that
avoid caffeine avoid alcohol don't smoke
or use nicotine especially within the
hours preceding bed avoid super high
intensity exercise right before bed
usually I think just a couple hours is
enough to wind down from that but you
know obviously you don't want to finish
a sprint workout and hop right into bed
bedroom should be dark quiet kind of
cool you don't want it to be warm and
then they had some other tips and tricks
now the blue blockers are getting pretty
popular I know Eric Helms reviewed a
study on them in mass a couple issues
ago so avoiding blue lights specifically
a couple hours before bed can be a nice
thing one of the things I find
interesting is now they're putting a lot
of those LED stadium lights in and like
LED streetlights those things are awful
in terms of the amount of blue light
they emit so like if you're in like an
outdoor you know flag football league
and you're playing till like 11:00 at
night under some lights that actually
might be tough it might be pretty tough
a good idea is to get some bright
natural light in the morning so this
blue light it works both ways right so
it kind of stimulates wakefulness so
it's nice to be exposed to light in the
morning but to try to kind of withdraw
from that within the hours before bed
one one on the list that people hate
don't hit the snooze button that that's
a battle that a lot of people have given
up on and I'm one of them I need to get
better at that if you use your computer
at night there are some things you can
do to reduce the amount of blue light
that's coming out of it either via
software or I think there are actually
physical covers as well that you can get
higher carbohydrate meals especially
high glycemic index foods at night might
be helpful super high fat meals right
before bed can be a little bit
detrimental and some people really
struggle if they have really spicy high
fat meals before bed kind of keeps them
up from just their Gi being a little
upset melatonin can work I don't want to
get into all the specifics on how to dos
in time that because it's kind of a
whole can of worms there but that's
really the only supplement I've ever
felt really
solid about as it pertains to sleep
there's a bunch out there but melatonin
is kind of the king of the sleep
supplements I think don't fall asleep
with the TV on and I would say you
probably don't want to do that with the
radio on either you want to eliminate
any kind of stimulation that's gonna
disturb your your sleep quality here's
one that's really really big that people
forget you got a tape or your fluid
throughout the day you you shouldn't be
waking up twice to urinate in the middle
of the night a lot of people that like
are like no I got a drink two gallons of
water a day or something especially in
the physique athlete world
you got a taper that stuff down there's
nothing cool about having to wake up and
didn't you say you used to purposely
make yourself do that yeah so I used to
it was when we were talking about
drinking a protein shake in the middle
of the night
yeah I'd purposefully drink a bunch
before I went to bed so I I could wake
up in the middle of the night from my
protein shake did you violate like every
single aspect of this list No so dude
like these days I'm doing virtually
everything on this list and I except
except for the first one of waiting
until I'm sleepy to go to bed everything
else I'm mostly doing I'm being a good
boy okay I'm sleeping at least six
nights a week it's been awesome what's
your average hours per night you think I
don't know so I pulled an all-nighter
this week to finish an article but I
would say in general I'm probably
averaging eight and sometimes that's
like getting in bed staring at the
ceiling and getting five and getting
like 11 or 12 on the weekends but yeah I
mean I'm I'm sleeping more like a real
person these days that's good all right
last two as they already mentioned
sleeping in a cool room tends to help
out quite a bit and check your mattress
might be too old that's a helpful tip
but yes there's a lot of different
things you can do that affect your not
just the amount of sleep you get but
also your sleep quality I think that's
something that people should consider a
lot of times people it's like well
I went to bed at this specific time and
I woke up at that specific time but
sometimes they fail to account for the
fact that they're rolling around all
night and they're still tired all day
despite the amount of sleep they're
getting sleep quality is also really
important so there are some people who
even though technically they sleep seven
hours a night or something it's like we
still probably ought to look at this
checklist and reevaluate if you're
potentially hurting your sleep quality
which is still causing you to be really
tired throughout the day just one more
thing I would note as well since there
are I mean I would assume virtually
everyone who listens to this podcast is
a lifter if you're doing everything you
think you should be doing and you're in
bed for enough hours and you do still
feel super tired all the time it's not a
bad idea to go get checked for sleep
apnea that does disproportionately
affect lifters because one of the main
risk factors for it is having a thick
neck and so I mean I don't think a ton
of people do neck training but I think
most people's necks just naturally get a
little bit thicker from lifting so yeah
if you do constantly feel super tired
all the time
if a partner has complained about you
snoring constantly not a bad idea to get
checked for sleep apnea yeah I recently
was struggling to sleep for I mean for
like a million different reasons but one
of them was I was waking up because I
was breathing poorly and I have a
deviated septum from wrestling because I
used to just slam my face into people my
go-to wrestling move and it explains a
lot about my current appearance but so I
thought it was like oh well you know
deviated septum hard to breathe and then
I started using like an allergy nasal
spray and it's like nope you just had
allergies just didn't address it for
like six months
but yeah so anyway moral of the story is
make sure you're breathing well when you
sleep as well but yeah it's a lot of
that stuff's pretty obvious but I think
I think a lot of people and I've fallen
into this trap as well it's like when
you're sleeping poorly it's like
something that has happened to you that
you have no ability to influence you're
like well thusly
gods have frowned upon me lately and
it's like well there's actually some
behaviors that you can that you can
proactively address to try to increase
the likelihood that you'll get good
sleep sometimes people will go through
all these and there's something else
going on that they have to go and get
some assistance with you know go see a
sleep specialist your physician might
refer you to do like an overnight
observation period so it's it's not to
say like if you're if you're sleeping
poorly it's your fault
because you're not doing things but it
is nice to know that there are things
you can proactively manipulate to try to
enhance your likelihood of sleeping well
okay we got another question for Greg
here it's by Conor Flynn if soreness
isn't a good indicator of gains how do
you tell how hard you should be training
ok so super simple and straightforward
answer to this one just track your
progress let so track your training
track your progress keep good records of
everything and just see how hard you
have to train to make gains so it seems
like a assumption or an assumption
underlying this question is that the way
you feel you know either later in the
day after a training session or the day
or two following a training session
should be indicative to you of whether
or not it was effective and I I don't
think that that's a good way to approach
it simply because like measurable
adaptations for people past the very
early beginner stages of training do
take weeks or months to accrue and so
the way you're feeling you know hours or
days after a training session isn't
going to be very indicative it can't be
very indicative of you know what's going
on over that entire multi week or multi
month period and so yeah I think your
best approach is just keeping good
records like a pen and paper journal now
there are apps that people use to track
their training one that I recommend full
disclosure I'm on their board
it's called gravitas I believe it's it's
still
only available available for iOS but
it's really good or you could just like
use a spreadsheet I use spreadsheets I
love spreadsheets but just have some way
that you're tracking your training like
you know what your training volume is
you know what exercises you're doing you
know your frequency and you have some
way to monitor progress it doesn't
necessarily have to be going for one rep
maxes even though that's not a bad way
to track progress if you're a
powerlifter obviously but you know maybe
your bread and butter workout is three
sets of ten if you're you know being
able to lift more weight for three sets
of ten on the same exercise than you
were three months previously that tells
you you were training hard enough
progress is occurring good things are
happening so yeah you in general in
general if you're going for like a
feeling after a training session I kind
of think a decent subjective way to feel
after a session is kind of like you wake
up the next day and you're like well I
couldn't do that same workout again
today but I don't feel like dog [ __ ] I
think that's kind of what you're aiming
for like maybe a little achy a little
tired but not like trash I think that's
not a bad subjective feeling to shoot
for which is kind of more
all-encompassing than just soreness of
the prime movers that you just trained
but yeah that's still I think way worse
than just actually tracking stuff
monitoring progress monitoring your
training volume and just simply seen
well am I making gains if so cool I have
been training hard enough that's
probably a pretty good guide for how
hard I need to train moving forward have
I not been making gains and do I feel
fresh all the time well then I probably
wasn't training hard enough I need to do
more to make gains in the future or am I
not making gains and I feel like [ __ ]
and worn down all the time well maybe I
was training too hard or you know maybe
I wasn't sleeping well maybe I wasn't
taking care of business outside the gym
but yeah just obtained
active markers of performance and
training volume like I I think that
that's what you should monitor and and
used to tell you whether you've been
training hard enough and if your urines
Brown you trained too hard true yes okay
question for Eric what are the best ways
to do concurrent cardio so low intensity
training or high intensity training
along with lifting yes I've got a brief
anecdote about this I was in Finland and
I was talking about bodybuilding contest
preparation from a research perspective
and I didn't really study up on the
event too much before I went there I
knew what I was gonna do I knew the
general context and I was like perfect
and I got there the first day and I was
like I probably should have considered
the fact that professor Hawking was
there as was you ha-ah tnan and so like
most of the really good concurrent
training research for the last like ever
basically came out of out of their lab
and I was like oh god I have some slides
on concurrent training I was like this
is not my bread-and-butter like but it
seemed prudent when you're talking about
bodybuilders who are lifting and doing a
ton of cardio a lot of times so I was
really really scared because they were
in the audience I was like I hope they
agree with me because if not then I'm
clearly wrong you know yeah I'm not
gonna argue with them but in any case as
I presented my slides they smiled and
nodded the whole time so that was a good
sign someone else at the event also did
a talk specifically about concurrent
training and all of our general
recommendations lined up quite well so I
walked away feeling very good about
myself now when it comes to concurrent
training there's a really nice review by
an author the last name is I'm gonna
it's gonna sound like a disease when I
say this that's clearly not how you
pronounce it to me it looks like methan
itis
that's how it looks to me too okay but
it came out in 2018 very nice review
talking about concurrent training
obviously that there is some potential
to experience an interference effect and
that is if you're doing a ton of aerobic
training and a ton of resistance
training the signaling pathways that
that precede adaptations in the muscle
to each of these types of training they
are to some extent at odds with each
other and we do see as I kind of talked
about in my presentation in Finland
nervously when you see interventions
where people are doing a ton of cardio
and a ton of lifting you do tend to see
an interference effect present but when
they start getting a little bit more
careful about the overall volume of both
those are the interventions where you
really don't see much of a pronounced
interference effect and so there are
things you can do when it comes to
intensity volume and timing that very
much reduced the likelihood of a
significant interference effect okay can
I just throw one thing in here yes so
most most people listening to this are
probably either primarily have
hypertrophy or strength goals the other
aspect of the interference effect that's
not talked about quite as often is the
impact of concurrent training versus
resistance training alone on power
output or like high-velocity stuff and
the literature as far as like strength
and I perch bigos does show that yeah
you can mess with some of these
variables and either negate the
interference effect or at least minimize
it pretty substantially the stuff on
power output is a little bit more dire
the interference effect is larger it's
just a larger way way larger yeah it
shows up in more context etc so like if
you're just trying to build big legs or
improve your squad and you want to do
some cardio like yeah you'll probably be
fine
if you take the advice that Erik's about
to give but if you know if you're trying
to put four inches on your vertical
probably not the best idea yeah that's a
really good point it's pretty wild when
you see the drop in power in some of
those studies
with the interference effect or just the
lack of power adaptations that take
place power is usually more effective
than strength and strength is usually a
little more effective than hypertrophy
generally speaking so I'm of the opinion
that hypertrophy is the only thing that
actually matters and so that's what my
answer is written from that perspective
so with all these things you know power
is tricky but if you really want to
include cardio and you really want to
avoid the interference effect the first
thing you want to do is be really
cautious about how much of both you're
doing and so like the thing I brought up
in my slides about physique athletes is
like you'll see competitors in case
studies and it's like they were lifting
90 minutes a day six days a week and
they were doing at least four hours of
cardio a week that's a lot that and
they're all by the way they're also
eating at an enormous deficit like
they're interfering all over the place
but that's kind of the nature of the
game but something that you can do is
try to you know limit the number of
times per week that you're doing what I
would call a real aerobic bout of
exercise if you're taking a 30 minute
walk just to get your energy expenditure
up I don't consider that part of the
game here we're talking about something
where you're jogging or more in terms of
intensity in my opinion or you know
getting on the bike and doing some real
dedicated peddling I'll walk around the
neighborhood I think you could probably
do that to your heart's content assuming
it's not an outrageous number of hours
you're spending doing that per day
you're probably not gonna interfere with
much at all in my opinion now I would
say the more you can limit your cardio
sessions certainly the more you can
limit the interference effect the tricky
thing is a lot of times people will say
you try to prefer high intensity
intervals rather than you know lower
intensity steady-state cardio to an
extent that's okay and the understanding
there is that when we took a look at the
different molecular pathways that are
stimulated by high-intensity interval
training there are less at odds with
what we're trying to achieve with
strength training when you compare it to
like traditional aerobic exercise the
problem is if and we've talked about
this on the podcast before as everybody
found out in about 2010 if you just do
like nine sessions of hit per week
you're going to die like you're gonna be
so fatigued and tired you're gonna
perform like crap so you have to strike
a balance there like it's very easy to
look at the molecular pathways and say
oh we'll do the high-intensity stuff but
that fails to factor in the fact that
really high intensity stuff will wreck
you especially if you're lifting several
times a week as well so I think you have
to strike a balance there I usually
don't like to see people doing unless
they really need to more than two or
three cardio bouts per week and I
usually don't like to see more than one
or two of them behind tensity interval
type workouts but yet you have to get in
there and and work at an individual
level and figure out what can we
actually accommodate in terms of
recovery and you have to be really I
would err on the side of caution and say
let's get away with as minimal cardio as
we can as the starting point and work up
from there and see how much you can do
before you start to really interfere
with just overall fatigue day to day the
ability to perform the ability to
recover another thing you can do is
separate the training bouts out so
there's all these different studies
looking at like which one goes first
right aerobic training or resistance
training if you're doing them at the
same workout right so if you're gonna go
in the gym and do both what you do first
so the the most recent meta-analysis on
that I forget who the author was but
there were two groups that published
basically the same meta-analysis in the
same month just in different journals
yeah both looking at this question and
if memory serves the the order that they
were performed in didn't affect gains in
aerobic performance but doing the
resistance training first was better for
strength and I per trophy yeah if you
look at the interference effect
literature it'd be real
the ideal if you could separate those
out into different sessions I think
mm-hmm
so a lot of times they'll say if you can
get away with it do your your resistance
training and your cardio or aerobic
training on separate days kind of
alternate throughout the week but but
they do say at minimum it would be nice
if you're really focused on strength
power hypertrophy gains if you could
ideally give yourself at least a good
three to six hours of separation between
your cardio about and your resistance
training valve so I mean the more you
can separate them the better but they
tend to say at least three to six hours
if separating them is not an option and
you're interested mostly in strength and
hypertrophy then you're gonna do
strength first followed by the cardio
about and then finally one thing to keep
in mind when you're balancing the
overall volume and frequency of these
workouts is keeping your main goal in
mind so what they recommend in this
particular review which I agree with is
if your main focus is on your resistance
training adaptations you probably
shouldn't be doing three cardio bouts
for every lifting bout you have like the
numbers don't make sense there so you
want to do a ratio of two to one or
three to one resistance training bouts
two cardio bouts per week and they say
you know obviously that that ratio can
get a lot more even if if the main focus
is on aerobic training but you know a
lot of times you'll see people who their
main focus is resistance training but
they're trying to lean out and they're
doing as many cardio bouts per week as
resistance training bouts and I think
that's probably that's probably going a
little a little too far with the cardio
especially if they're pretty vigorous
bouts
mm-hmm if I can add one thing to this as
well so this is this is something that's
a little bit more tentative and I just
kind of I guess discovered it in the
literature this past month when I was
writing an article for mass but it kind
of seems that if you are doing
concurrent training that it may be a
little bit more important to also make
sure you
not doing your resistance training to
failure so the thing that put me on to
this is there was a paper published last
month by Carol at all where they had one
group training to failure not every set
to failure but every set pretty close to
failure and the last set of every
exercise to failure and then the other
group training generally about two to
six reps shy of failure did that for ten
weeks if memory serves and they were
also doing to sprint training sessions
per week and by and large what you see
in the literature if you look at like
the failure verses non failure stuff is
either more hypertrophy when training to
failure or similar hypertrophy between
the two conditions in this paper the
group not training to failure had
significantly larger increases in
anatomical cross-sectional area of the
quads and non significant larger
differences so like kind of leaning in
that direction but p-value not quite
below 0.05 for type one fiber cross
sectional area tie two fiber cross
sectional area and vastus lateralis
thickness as well so this is really kind
of the first study I've seen in that
body of literature leaning really hard
in favor of not training to failure and
so the interesting thing is they did
have a couple cardio sessions per week
in that study as well so I went back and
looked through the concurrent training
literature to see the concurrent
training studies where the concurrent
training group actually grew more than
the group only doing resistance training
and I could find four studies two of
them it's kind of hard to parse they
were by Lundberg at all if memory serves
and the resistance training was
isokinetic stuff so it's it's hard to
know exactly how that would apply to
just normal isotonic training the other
two though one was by Cassie or at all
and one was by Nicola at all and in both
of those studies the majority of the
training
was not done to failure so in the Casio
study I want to say like 18 out of the
21 training sessions weren't to failure
and in the McCullough study I want to
say 14 out of the 21 weeks of training
weren't done to failure which is pretty
cool like 20 one-week training studies
is pretty long for the literature and so
both of those studies saw more
hypertrophy when doing concurrent
training versus only resistance training
and in the Carroll paper it's all more
hypertrophy so it was two concurrent
training groups but one of them wasn't
training to failure and they had more
growth than the group training to
failure
so that's notable because for most of
the of the training literature that's
out there you just have people do
resistance training to failure because
that's a good way to you know
standardize stuff and make sure people
are actually training hard and not just
sandbagging you the whole time and so it
it's something where I one could
potentially theorize that rather than an
interference effect maybe it's slightly
synergistic doing cardio plus non
failure training that may be a bit of a
stretch but I think what we can say with
slightly more confidence than that is if
you are doing concurrent training I
think it becomes even more important for
your resistance training to not be done
to failure maybe just because the added
fatigue of training to failure when
compounded with the extra fatigue from
the concurrent training really just digs
you into a bigger hole and the other
thing I'll note which I don't think you
touched on is that when you look at the
interference effect literature it's
really only for the lower body so the
studies that have looked at whether
doing like you know running or cycling
affects hypertrophy you see it with
lower body stuff but not upper body
stuff yeah so you know if you compete in
the board shorts division and you just
need to look good from the waist up
probably doesn't really matter I think I
would suspect that it doesn't matter
based on the literature we had
i but i would also caution people who do
compete in the physique division
you know boardshorts not to get too
attached to like interference effect
happens on a spectrum right yeah yeah i
mean it's clearly something where the
dose makes the poison right yeah so the
thing that always kills me is like when
people are it's like you're you know
competing in something that is
theoretically based on especially if
your natural doing physique the physique
category you're still trying to get as
big as you can like there there's no way
natural who's like huh just too big
there's probably like for for physique
competitors out there who are like yeah
and he did I need to chill but
realistically like I I mean it can we
just say it like physique it's like it
was made for the non-tested Federation
so people didn't have to have like a
million grams of tests per week yeah
isn't that pretty much the deal that
we're comfortable with yeah so like in
natural like you're still trying to get
big and the thing that kills me is when
people are dieting hard and lifting hard
and they're doing six hours of moderate
intensity cardio per week it's like
maybe it's not the same interference
effect that we're seeing you know that
kind of local within within the
particular muscles acting but your
lifting is gonna suck yeah and another
thing to note is the concurrent training
literature we have isn't also looking at
people in big calorie deficits right and
one just fun little physiology fact for
people out there is if you're in a big
calorie deficit and carbs are low as
well doing doing lower body cardio stuff
can cause glycogen depletion in your
upper body via the wonders of the
lactate shuttle where basically like you
can metabolize carbohydrate into lactate
in like your arms back shoulders
whatever and then that lactate is
shuttled to your lower body converted
back into carbohydrate and used for
aerobic or anaerobic metabolism so yeah
that
is a good point in in the literature it
doesn't really seem like the
interference effect really hits the
upper body all that much assuming you're
doing lower body dominant cardio but
yeah it wouldn't shock me of things
changed in an energy deficit or
especially if you're doing really really
high volumes of cardio ok question for
Greg what effects can active release
therapy acupuncture massages and
stretching have on training so that's a
good question and I'm mostly only going
to answer the back half of it I'm not
aware of much research at all on Active
Release therapy and I know what it is I
know how it's marketed and how it's
supposed to work but I just haven't seen
much high-quality research on it period
I'm not saying it doesn't exist that's
just not an area of research I pay much
attention to and in the handful of
journals that would publish a arty
research theoretically I haven't come
across it when doing the journal sweeps
for mass so I don't think there's that
much out there with acupuncture
acupuncture is one of those things where
it occasionally seems to have an effect
but only not in placebo-controlled
studies and so someone may be wondering
what is a placebo controlled acupuncture
study and so there's two ways you can do
one the first way is like acupuncture is
based on a bunch of ideas that are
largely unproven about how like Chi
throat flows through the body and how
you can like how Jeavons are like muscle
knots or something can block the flow of
Chi and like the needles can help the
Chi flow better and whatnot and so one
way you can do a chant for acupuncture
is like some people get the needles put
where the needles are supposed to go to
release the Chi and other people just
get needles put in like random spots
that are like close to those positions
and the other way which i think is it's
cooler personally is some people
actually get
needles stuck in them and some people
just get poked with toothpicks which
like I I don't know how good of a sham
treatment that is because I've never had
like traditional Chinese medicine type
acupuncture done but I've I've had dry
needling done on me before and I feel
like I'd be able to tell the difference
between a needle going in and just being
stuck with a toothpick what's the pain
level on dry needling low really I mean
like it's it's weird it's like for me at
least it
it's low-grade pain and also low to
moderate grade tickly yeah it feels
weird
I don't know but but it feels
substantially different than getting
poked with a toothpick it's very
different okay
but yeah so basically in the in the
studies where there's no sham treatment
or placebo acupuncture maybe seems to do
some stuff but when you introduce a sham
treatment to compare it against it
doesn't really seem to do anything that
the sham treatment doesn't do and so
like there's a general principle that if
if someone's dealing with some [ __ ] like
kind of doing anything kind of helps a
little bit
so as far as acupuncture goes it's
probably that acupuncture itself doesn't
really do [ __ ] but just going to have
someone do something to you that is
theoretically supposed to help helps you
out even if what they're actually doing
is generally ineffective so that's a RT
in acupuncture massages and stretching
though there is more high-quality
research on that and for massages they
actually seem to be really good stuff
there was a meta-analysis that I
reviewed for mass a while back that it
it synthesized the findings of like a
hundred and thirty different studies
that looked at different recovery
modalities or different modalities
purported to be recovery modalities so
that included massage it included
just like active recovery
it included stretching it included water
immersion compression garments probably
a few more that I'm forgetting but
probably like 10 to 12 different
therapies and within that meta-analysis
post-workout massages seemed to do the
best for for both like objective
recovery of performance after a hard
training session and if memory serves
that meta-analysis also looked at like
subjective like personal assessments of
soreness and and recovery and so
post-workout massages seem to be really
good the thing to note there though is
in the studies that look at the effects
of massage on recovery from exercise
it's generally like you do a really
intense training session and then
immediately get a massage so it's not
like you know you do several weeks of
training and now you're getting kind of
sore and your joints are cranky and then
you go get a massage like that's not
what the research is on it's like you
know you know you're doing a brutal
deadlift day and you schedule a massage
where you can drive straight from the
gym to the massage parlor and so in that
context massage seems to be great I
don't know I haven't seen much research
on massages used I think the way people
typically use them as just kind of a way
to feel better after several accumulated
weeks of training so I'm not so sure
about that but yes directly post
exercise massages are great stretching I
think is a little bit misunderstood so I
remember man so back in you know back in
the 90s and early 2000s everyone was
like super Pro stretching if you were on
any sports team ever
your coach would have you do some sort
of static stretching before exercise
just thought you know that was a part of
any complete warm-up it would help
prevent injuries help improve
performance whatever like everyone was
all about stretching and then some
research started coming out showing that
Wow maybe pre exercise stretching
doesn't really
effect injury risk may be intense pre
exercise stretching can decrease
philosophy can decrease power output and
then everyone got super anti stretching
roundabouts
what would you say Erik maybe like 2005
or so I'd say that's when it started and
you know I mean I would say in like Oh
809 by about 2011 that's when it's like
if you were like hey why don't we get
around and stretch it'd be like you're a
joke yeah yeah who invited you
so and and that's kind of where people
still are today yeah so go like them
we felt betrayed by all of the
stretching we had to do growing up some
research came out that said maybe
stretching isn't the bee's knees and so
now like almost without context a lot of
people are super anti stretching and
especially static stretching you know
some people say like I may be like
active stretching that's kind of good
but what's the difference between active
stretching and just like a normal
dynamic warm-up like I don't think there
is one but yeah people aren't crazy
about static stretching and I think that
that is probably not a bad way to be in
the pre workout like warm-up window but
I do think that there are some some
instances where stretching is still
really useful that people have just lost
nuance from being just super anti
stretching and so what we know is that
doing really intense static stretching
right before some sort of physical
performance can decrease force output
decrease power output if you do really
intense stretching right before
resistance training so you know you're
you're doing the leg press and you
stretch your quads super hard right
before each set you actually see
decreased hypertrophy from that so
that's no good but if you do white sets
of stretching between exercises that
seems like it may actually increase
hypertrophy a little bit so at this
point I believe there's only one study
on it
and I think it's I think it's from
D'Souza
yeah I was gonna say I think that's from
the Sousa and I'm pretty sure he's
working on a follow-up to that in
trained lifters now but in the in the
prior study it was on untrained lifters
and the stretching they had them doing
between sets was light stretching so it
was below the point of discomfort I want
to say if it was like a scale from zero
to ten where zero is no stretch at all
in ten is super intense intensely
painful stretch grade three tear yeah
yeah pretty much I want to say the prior
study had had people at like a four ish
so like light stretching between sets in
one study has boosted hypertrophy so
that's pretty cool and then we're
stretching is still really useful I
think is away from training so you know
not like super intense stretching during
a workout not stretching when you're
warming up to train but maybe after a
session and certainly like you know
maybe in the morning hours before a
training session or at night hours after
a training session there was again a
systematic review that I looked at for
mass that was looking at the effects of
prolonged stretching interventions on
muscular performance and most of the
studies so I want to say all of the
studies in that systematic review either
found a neutral or positive effect I
don't think any of them found a negative
effect on on muscular performance but
yeah like so one of the things that I
think most people know is that acute
static stretching doesn't really cause
changes in range of motion all that much
so you know you stretch your hamstrings
hold that stretch for like two or three
minutes you get deeper into it
cool ten minutes later you no longer
have more hamstring extensibility than
you did prior to stretching but chronic
static stretching does improve joint
range of motion tissue extensibility
like it does cause those chronic
and it it seems like it may help
increase muscle force as well and
there's at least one study by Simpson
and colleagues that found that just
doing really intense static stretching
of the calves actually caused calf
growth in the absence of training so
like stretching can improve range of
motion can improve tissue extensibility
may help improve strength like augment
the resistance training you're doing
light stretching between sets may boost
growth none of those things are gonna
make a night-and-day difference like no
one is small because they didn't stretch
enough but it it can still have benefits
just not as intense static stretching
while you're warm enough for exercise
okay so the final question I was
actually on I was a guest on James wall
shammies podcast one of the concepts
that kind of came up we talked for like
an hour and a half so it was a very
small portion of what we talked about
but one of the things that came up that
I thought was a good question that he
posed was how do you reconcile you know
valuing research with the likelihood
that there's some degree of pretty bad
research out there and that a lot of
people can't really tell the difference
between good and bad research you know
so how do you tell somebody go dig into
this research knowing that there's
probably very small amol amount of stuff
that's kind of like fraudulent a decent
amount that might be poorly done or
poorly interpreted by the researchers
themselves and then also the fact that
most people won't be able to really
discern the good studies from the bad so
how do you reconcile that that's a good
question
so I mean one of the things I'll say is
I feel like I feel like it's not that
much of a problem because there's not
that many people that actually read
research in the first place so like I
have cite data for stronger by science
obviously
and I can look at how many page views we
have and how many clicks on though like
on links within the pages take place and
so I can see what the likelihood is that
a page view will result in someone
clicking over to like clicking a PubMed
link or going to a journal site and you
know I don't know from there if they're
reading the full text or just skimming
abstracts or just clicked it by accident
but just simply going to one of those
places to theoretically look at an
abstract and maybe read the full text
and it's like one out of a thousand page
views actually results in someone going
to a journal site so I mean I would say
our audience is a lot more science savvy
and interested in and passionate about
research than most online fitness folks
like I feel very confident saying that
and still basically no one in our
audience is seemingly is interested in
reading the research that we talk about
so part part of me thinks that it can't
be that big of a problem because there's
not that many people trying in the first
place and then the other thing I'll say
is I think I think that it's important
for I think it's important for people
who do talk about research to not
idealize it too much and not be salesmen
almost because like the whole point of
science is it's supposed to be like
objective and circumspect and I think
that I think that one issue that's out
there with science communication
generally is a lot of folks are more
cheerleaders for the concept of science
than people willing to like pull back
the veil on how dirty it can be at times
which I I kind of get because there is
like an anti science
anti intellectual sentiment that I don't
think is the majority of the culture but
it at least runs through the culture and
so if you're like Neil deGrasse Tyson or
Bill Nye you don't want to go out there
and say like hey
what like maybe half of the research in
psychology doesn't replicate like that
that would be a good way to you know
really reinforce really bad ideas that a
lot of people have about science um but
I think that within a community of
people who do generally value science I
think at that point you don't want to be
a cheerleader anymore and you do need to
be open about the fact that like yes
some of this stuff isn't that good and I
think that that in and of itself helps
provide a shield against people who
might go into it with too much naivete
because like I think some people just
aren't on the lookout for bad stuff they
think peer review is perfect and if
something gets past peer review and
published it's good [ __ ] and if people
know that that's not always the case
they at least know to look for some
stuff and then if you tell them hey
here's some stuff that you should look
for I wrote a whole article about this
on stronger by science like some of the
hallmarks of research that could be
sketchy or research that's really good
which we can link in the show notes if
you know some of the things to look for
then that helps a lot and then the last
thing I would say is like I would say I
mean I know the path I took
I assume it's similar to the path you
took I think it's the path that a lot of
people who read research more
skeptically took is just like I think
everyone kind of goes into it wide-eyed
and bushy tailed and thinks that
everything's great and then you know you
read something about the replication
crisis and you're like oh maybe this
isn't perfect you come across a handful
of papers where you're like ooh I don't
consider myself an expert but I'm pretty
sure that this is [ __ ] and then just
over time you develop more and more
scepticism and you learn more and more
ways to pick out stuff that may be
suggestive that something is an awesome
so I I mean I think as with most things
you try something at first you suck at
it and you
better at it over time like I know I'm I
know I'm better at interpreting research
now than I was when I first started
writing about research on stronger by
science like or well at the time Greg
novels calm like seven years ago like I
sucked ass at interpreting research back
then I was terrible but like I've done a
bunch of it and I've gotten better and I
think that I think that a lot of times
not just with interpreting research but
in all things people worry too much
about well what if someone tries this
and they're bad it's like well of course
they'll be bad like you're bad at
everything until you're good at it and
so yeah I mean I think I I think most
people will interpret research poorly
and be too naive about it when they
first start doing it and that doesn't
bother me because as I see it as long as
they stick with it they'll probably get
better over time
and an important part of that process is
especially when you're first starting
out so you want to subscribe to mass
read the papers we talk about check your
interpretations against ours that's
that's the number one way I honestly
don't know of a different way to get
into it I wasn't gonna mention our
product by name I know I that was but
that was a little sarcastic I mean it's
a great product I would recommend you do
that but yeah the the the boldface nough
sub that sales pitch was mint somewhat
as a joke but no it's really important I
think when you're first trying to figure
out like am I good at interpreting this
stuff to check and see how other people
interpreted the same thing
mm-hm you know because like the thing
that scares me a lot of times about
taking a totally self-taught approach in
anything without having anyone else in
your circle or some kind of mentor or
somebody to keep you on track it's like
you could do a thing but if it's
completely self-guided and you never
have any checks in the process you could
just be wrong many many many many times
for as long as you'd like but trying to
figure out like having some kind of
outside some kind of check in place to
figure out if
actually getting it or not I think is
big the other thing you mentioned the
process for a lot of people is you come
into it very naive and just assuming
well it got published I'm sure it's fine
mm-hmm so my trajectory was kind of
similar but I think the people who go
straight through with their education
because you took an interesting route I
mean you got into the interpreting
research game before going back to grad
school mm-hmm
the thing that I've seen with people who
go straight through their schooling
right off the gate right off the bat
like right out of the gate is you start
out very naive the same place and you
think well if it got published I'm sure
it's perfect but then in grad school you
take your first class where they teach
you to like be skeptical of research and
then you start tearing every study apart
like you have no context for it but you
just open a paper and say I'm gonna find
a bunch of annoying things to complain
about and you open it up and you're like
16 weeks for a training study I would
have done 60 oh man you know you know
it's so obvious when people are in that
stage because it's their complaints are
always well study should have been four
years long and wouldn't it have been
great if they had 200 subjects like like
that those are the two main complaints
everyone has it's like dude come on like
yeah it's always like well if you're
gonna do a deck so the least you could
do is feed them all their meals for
three days prior who knows what their
glycogen was like it's like dude all we
want to know is their fat free mass
index who cares but I mean yeah so it I
think some people depending on their
trajectory also fall into this very
treacherous valley of being so hyper
critical but adding no value in their
critique yeah it's it's like yeah I know
some highlights to complain about and
then there it's like and then then those
very same students have to do a thesis
project oh dog so the one that pisses me
off the most I think I've talked about
this on the show before but holy [ __ ]
this pisses me off is when a paper
reports an association makes no causal
claims about that association whatsoever
and then [ __ ] get on social
media and they're like
while correlation doesn't prove
causation it's like you you dumb [ __ ]
no one said that it proved causation
like you're just pulling this [ __ ] out
of thin air to jerk yourself off like no
one's no one saying it's causal like you
look you look stupid
stop it correct people do that all the
time and it it makes me so mad yeah but
it is funny when those students like you
know one month into into grad school
they're tearing apart every paper and
then they do their thesis project and
after they do a research project they're
like okay maybe I should lighten up yeah
yeah so I if I could make my own very
obvious sales pitch the thing that I
like about the group we have doing mass
is that because we've all done original
research we don't take that route of
just doing like cliche like mu it's just
a correlation could have been six times
longer could have had 300 more subjects
but but yeah I mean the thing that I
would always that I would tell people
who get a little annoyed when they see
that like well if there's bad research
out there how am I supposed to tell how
much to value this stuff is not to let
that discourage you because there's a
whole lot of people who are doing
extremely good research there's a whole
lot of people who in all sorts of
different platforms are interpreting
that research and trying to make it
accessible and turn it in the guideline
so there is a a post publication
filtration process that kind of happens
at all sorts of different levels all
sorts of different platforms but but I
guess my biggest question is like so if
you're not gonna value the research the
hell do you have like it's kind of the
best we can do if we're trying to be
objective about making sense of some of
these questions you know so if you're
gonna say add the research I don't
really value it because some of its not
as good as the rest of it and you're
gonna throw that out entirely what are
you left with yeah it's almost like that
uh I'm gonna butcher this but that
Churchill quote about democracy that's
exactly what I was thinking of yeah
like democracy sucks but it's the least
bad system we've found so far exactly
something
that extent yeah I have the same
approach for research like we can't
guarantee that everything that gets
published is gonna be perfect and
interpreted well and even applicable to
what you're doing but it's by far the
best thing we got yeah and and the other
thing I'll note as well is I think I
think it's improving all the time like I
mean just going back and looking at some
of the experimental designs and some of
the statistical reporting the stuff that
was being done in like the 90s things
have gotten a lot better since then
having conversations with people who are
in research about like open science
stuff and like replication stuff like
that and statistical reporting and just
stats in general a common thing that
people are saying is like the
reproducibility crisis in psychology and
biomedicine I think woke a lot of people
up in a lot of different fields and like
two or three years ago when a lot of
that stuff was coming out if I mentioned
problems with reproducibility and you
know P less than 0.05 doesn't
necessarily mean a finding is legit and
we'll replicate a lot of people in
exercise science would look at you like
he had a third eye like what the [ __ ]
are you saying like it has to be good
look how low that p-value is like
there's no trash getting publish but I
think that I think it was like a big
shock that took awhile to reverberate
through all of the sciences and I think
a lot more people have woken up to some
of the issues that had been in science
for a long time and so I mean I think
our fields improving I think all fields
are improving and I think that a lot of
the problems that exist in the
literature there are a lot of like very
smart very dedicated people who are
working at cleaning those things up in I
mean that's the beauty of science
because like most people who get into
science do get into it for the right
reasons by a lot yeah a wide margin for
sure cuz I mean
dude it's it's hard work yeah there's a
reason that me and Eric are not academia
I mean the the work to compensation
ratio with that level of education
doesn't really make sense unless you're
doing it because you love it and so I
mean I think most people mean well and
they're learning more about things that
they may have done previously that
weren't great and since most of the
people involved in the process do have
the right intentions and the right
motivations I think it's a system that
is easier to self-correct than most
systems would be so yeah like it's it's
not perfect it's I think better now than
it was 10 years ago I think it was
better 10 years ago than it was 20 years
ago and things are on a generally
positive trajectory
all right so as always thank you for
listening a little update we have a new
process for submitting questions we used
to have a very disorganized thread on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter that was
a nightmare to comb through so now we
actually have a Google Form that you can
you can go to the link and you can
submit your questions in there in a very
organized way and we always welcome your
questions so if you have a question that
you want answered on the show Greg
what's the the URL they can go to so you
can find it in the show notes or you can
just type in tiny dot CC slash SBS QA
for stronger by science question and
answer so very very easy and accessible
way to get your questions on the show
and we'd be happy to have them thanks
for listening we'll see you next time
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com to check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you